[Applause]
[Music]
for a man who's made a career out of
biding his time the moment had finally
come
and what a moment in a gilded coach
built to commemorate the 60th
anniversary of his mother's Reign the
new king and his Queen moved slowly in
the rain along the mall towards his long
pre-ordained date with royal destiny
waiting is the lot of the air apparent
but none has waited longer than chance
so it is that amid soaked but cheering
crowds a prince schooled in the ways of
one era becomes the Monarch for another
a very different brick
[Music]
at the Abbey that's witnessed such
occasions since 1066 Charles appeared
relaxed Queen Camilla understandably
perhaps lesser
[Applause]
foreign it was a coronation that in some
ways broke from tradition right from the
beginning a pledge to serve when greeted
by a young chorister from the King's
Chapel Royal
as children of the kingdom of God we
welcome you in the Name of the King of
Kings in his name and after his example
I come not to be served but to serve
but it was mainly of course a ceremony
draped in religion solemnity and history
the coronation oath has stood for
centuries
and is enshrined in law
are you willing to take the oath
I am willing
a coronation with the Archbishop of
Canterbury the Church of England and the
Bible resolutely at its heart
this of considerable interest to his son
and heirs Charles praise aloud and alone
give Grace that I may find in thy
service
perfect freedom
and in that freedom knowledge of thy
truth
grant that I may be a blessing to all
thy children
of every faith and belief
[Music]
s
and if that was a coronation first so
was this a practicing Hindu reading from
the Bible
for this cause we also
since the day we heard it do not cease
to pray for you
also a first female Church leader taking
part and a gospel choir
[Music]
the anointing of the king with holy oil
from the holy land is perhaps the most
sacred part of the ceremony
so sacred it is hidden from view
[Music]
what is not hidden is the crowning
it is the showpiece moment for the world
to see
it involves all sorts of regalia swords
orbs gloves and scepters
and of course the Saint Edwards crown
king of kings and Lord of lords bless we
beseech thee this crown
and so sanctify thy servant Charles upon
whose head this day thou Dost place it
for a sign of Royal Majesty that he may
be crowned with thy gracious favor and
filled with abundant grace and all
princely virtues
it is the moment he has thought about
and prepared for his entire life
it is a tight fit
but it is his
God Save the King
foreign
[Music]
a penny for the thoughts of young George
and for that matter his father
but for the youngest heir of them all
Louis in the front row here a long day
is clearly taking its toll
then the homage from the next in line to
the throne hi William Prince of Wales
pledge my loyalty to you and faith and
truth I will bear unto you as your lead
man of life and limb so help me God
and afterwards a more unusual request
I now invite
those who wish to offer their support to
do so I will pay true allegiance to your
majesty it was repeated here but the
country at large will have made what
they will have
[Music]
God Save the King
May the King live forever
and so to the crowning of Camilla she is
the Queen by marriage the love we're
told of Charles's life
whether she was quite prepared for this
is unclear
May thy servant Camilla who wears this
Crown be filled by thine abundant grace
and with all princely virtues what is
certain is that it is not being easy and
during vilification in the early days of
her public relationship with Charles
she has a key role and will fulfill it
say her admirers with a great sense of
Duty and little fanfare
there is no doubt she is his Queen they
will both be hoping that very soon she
becomes widely accepted as ours
understand
[Music]
as a country we may not have everything
but we certainly have a history a
thousand years and more
but this is also a day when we cast an
eye to the Future our future is a
country and yes as a monarchy what it
will look like how it will be viewed
indeed whether it survives
heavy indeed is the head that wears the
crown
but today was about marking a genuine
moment in that history of ours the start
of a new Carolina
but also about celebrating a new king he
was waiting most of his life and the job
he was born to do
[Music]